[Music]
oh
there is no greater scourge facing
america from within
the president takes the opioid crisis
very seriously
the kid got snagged at the border the
courier
took a year of undercover work to get
this far maybe it's dangerous to press a
big sale now
but what choice do we have
our product will be the first truly
non-addictive painkiller
what the hell is going on all the
addiction centers are
lighting up and then by day 10 they're
dead
[Music]
i'm looking for my son were you aware of
any issues
with your son like what
based on your results you want
northlight to pull their billion-dollar
drug
they can cost you a hell of a lot more
than your teaching job you've got to
have a plan
a plan for telling the truth
careful should this kid get an itch to
name names
it would be unpleasant for everyone
[Music]
what they're gonna come after you but
what you're doing now
may be the most important thing you ever
do
you had my son run drugs for you
this is the biggest public health crisis
chance tobacco it's not our
responsibility then who's is it
you cannot walk into that by alone we
can't quit
we can't stop
what do you think we're here to do to
make a difference
we can touch you anywhere in the world
we're running out of time
last chance
[Music]
you